I'm Tim Jakes and I am Scoutmaster with Troop 93 in Westchester, Pennsylvania.
This edition of Scoutmaster Podcast is sponsored by backers like me
And now the old Scoutmaster.
Hey, everybody, this is Clark Green. It's summertime and so our next few podcasts feature on-court presentations
from our archives. And this week I'm excited to play an interview with one of my absolute favorite outdoor authors,
Kevin Callan, who is called the Happy Camper.
Kevin is a Canadian author, canoeist and just a marvelous guy who's written a whole slew of books about camping
and guidebooks to the different parks in Canada,
And I always enjoy getting a chance to talk with him.
As always, this podcast is only possible because of the generosity of the folks who become ScoutmasterCGcom backers.
Go to ScoutmasterCGcom, click the support link at the top of the page.
You'll find out how you can become a ScoutmasterCGcom backer.
We'll be back with our regular schedule of podcasts in a few weeks.
Until then, let's get started, shall we?
Today I'm talking with Canadian author and canoe enthusiast, Kevin Callan, who is also known as the Happy Camper,
And we've seen some of his videos on the Scoutmaster blog before.
How are you doing Kevin?
How are you doing Clark? I am happy, Are you happy?
I am ecstatic because I'm talking to you.
Your book about Algonquin Provincial Park and canoe routes in Algonquin was really instrumental into us building a program where we bring our Scouts up that way.
Well, that's great. What do you think of Algonquin?
It's an amazingly different place.
I'm convinced you could go paddling in Algonquin and around there for 20 years and never see the same water twice.
Oh, definitely, There's lots of places to go. That's a nice thing about the park.
I mean, I only live an hour away from it, so that's the nicest thing too is I can just head up and paddle.
My favorite place is the Nipissing River, the northwest corner,
And it's just one of those tranquil little trope rivers that's hard to get to.
It's got old growth forest with old growth pine hang. It's just a beautiful place
Because it's like a transition zone.
The neat thing about Algonquin is that the forest ecology that's around that area continues south through southern Ontario or southeastern Ontario,
then right into the main area. you know the United States,
And it's this sort of corridor that's a lot of wildlife travel.
They figured out the last few years they've tracked the wolves and everything else and moose that travel this corridor all the time.
It's kind of neat that we actually have that.
And now let me get this right. Is it portaging or portaging?
Well, it depends on where you live.
It doesn't matter how you say it: Everybody hates one.
Bill Mason said it best when he said: people who actually like portaging is either a liar or a crazy.
And I got to say, though, the only thing that I think is left, though, that keeps wilderness wild, is a long portage,
Because, you think about it, if you go three miles with a canoe in your head and a pack on your shoulder and stuff,
what you're going to get at the end is going to be worth it.
I don't care how people get into the woods. to be quite honest, I'm not a purist,
But I know a lot of people that drive the ATVs and stuff,
And I'll go up to him. I said: look, you always get on my case that you go into this lake, and it's not what it was a few years back.
The reason why is it's too easy for you to get in here now,
And as soon as it's easy to get in, then the wilderness concept is gone and the trout are gone,
And if you actually put a canoe on your back and portage for three miles, then what you're going to get is going to be worth it.
And I think they're not getting that. They all want everything easy for them
And the nice thing is if you meet someone at the end of the portage- a really long portage- if you actually do see someone,
they're going to be just like you because they actually went through the same thing that you just did.
Well, and we should explain for the non canoe heads out there: a portage or a portage where you take all your gear,
But basically you're backpacking with a canoe.
Yeah, In fact, my wife loves backpacking. We always do a backpacking trip every year,
But I always curse at her: I go, you know, this is the longest portage ever.
You know all you're doing is walking with a pack on.
Yeah, There's no paddling involved at all. Come on.
No, what's with that?
There's a lot more canoeing in Ontario, isn't there?
Oh, yeah, We've got so many bodies of water that really the canoe was invented for the landscape.
Some say the landscape was invented for the canoe,
But it opened up Historically. it opened up Canada.
We should come back in Ontario.
And you know, Americans got the, I guess, the Chuck wagon and the cowboy hat, whatever. got to the west
We had the Voyager canoe,
So for a little bit of driving, if you're coming from New York State, Ohio, Pennsylvania or any of the New England states,
you can be in Canoe Paradise pretty quickly up over the line in Ontario.
Well yeah, if you're going from that area, you've got not only a Gonkwin, you've got Tomoghame,
which is actually just an hour or maybe a couple hours north of Gonkwin.
It's a vast wilderness in endless rivers. The Sturgeon River is one of my favorite
which is, oh you know, for three days it's almost continual class three or class one, class two rapids
And you won't see anybody.
You were talking a little bit about the Upper Ottawa.
Yeah, the Upper Ottawa, It was kind of a miracle.
My wife- actually my wife- has strict rules when we go on her holiday canoe trips.
I'm not allowed to work and ride about them.
My daughter was turning six years old and she said:
I want to go on another canoe trip for seven days.
I want to go somewhere we haven't gone before, which is not that easy, because I go everywhere
and wanted to be an easy trip and not a lot of portage.
Well, the Ottawa River. I never thought it would be the way it is,
But up from Mattawa, which is where the Champlain Park is. we started there
and we paddled down to what's called Driftwood Provincial Park,
which was halfway between Tomogamy and the city of Ottawa,
And you could do it in five days, but we did it in seven.
And there's no rapids, It's just a strong current.
There's one town halfway through and then we got supplies there,
But we saw 12 motor boats and that's it in seven days.
And we saw one other canoe group
And this is the Ottawa River,
Like everybody in Canada knows, the Ottawa River.
So on one side you had the Laurentian Mountains
and the other side you had the Ontario Bush,
And it was one of those things where you think you've seen it all
and then you realize that a lot of people ask me
what's my favorite canoe trip,
And it's always. it sounds bizarre,
but my answer is the next one. I'm going on
Because it really doesn't matter where you're going.
It matters that you go right.
I think you're absolutely right.
You just have to go.
There's just some marvelous opportunities for people
to take a group of scouts up there
and not to spend a whole lot of money,
And you can have a marvelous trip.
I guess you could probably throw a dart at a map of Ontario
and just go just about anywhere, couldn't you?
Oh yeah,
Then that's. the nice thing about it too
is that there's so many other places
outside of parks you can paddle,
Even in Northwestern Ontario. a couple of years ago
we went down what's called the Cupca River
and it's south of Wabakimi.
Now you can get to Wabakimi just by train
From the Toronto train station, for everything,
But they drop you off.
But we went down the Cupca
and it was one of those rivers that not many people knew.
In fact it was. Cliff Jegas, in an American nation,
told me about it
And we went down that river
and we paddled to Nipagon, the North Shore, Nipagon,
which is an oasis.
It's just so beautiful.
It's one of the inland sort of great lakes
And we spent five weeks paddling
and we weren't in the far north,
We didn't spend a fortune.
In fact it didn't cost as much at all to get to do that river.
So there's lots of places to go
and it's pretty cheap.
And any place that there's good paddling,
usually there's going to be an outfitter nearby-
Yeah, there usually is,
And there's a lot of information nowadays
on the computer obviously
to where to get the information
and if it's a good outfitter and that sort of thing.
But most likely in areas like really well used areas
like the Gonquin Tomography,
even Wabakimi or Quiddicoke,
there's at least a half a dozen outfitters
that are going to help you out.
And I don't own a canoe.
I do have a lovely paddle,
which is kind of like having a leash without a puppy.
Sometimes I think a paddle is more important to you
than the canoe.
You think about it.
You paddle 10,000 strokes a day on a good paddle day.
So, yeah, I'd sleep with my paddle if I were you.
It is really pretty simple
to get in with an outfitter
and to find your way up there.
You know you're working on a book right now
about some of the places to go canoeing in Ontario.
Yeah, what I did is I wrote eight guide books
throughout my years on where to go paddling
and come back in Ontario
And then my publisher said:
can you do the best of like the Beatles White Album
or whatever it's called,
I don't know.
But I said, yeah, I can do that,
but I'd like to add new ones as well.
And what they did is that
I chose 40 of my favorite roots in Ontario
and then 10 new ones
And that'll be out in March
And it's called Terrell's Best Canoe Roots.
Yeah,
But there's some new ones, though
that really might interest you
because it's not really being written about before.
And there's an old canoe route
in the south end of Tomoghani.
There's a place called Chinakuchi.
Now there's a place near Chinakuchi.
This is just north of a gulking park
that is called Kalarni Park.
Now that is the most scenic place
in Ontario, Kalarni Park.
It's got quartzite mountains,
It's got turquoise water.
But there's a place near there,
near Sudbury, called Chinakuchi,
And it's a south access to Tomoghani.
But what I did is I went up to Chinakuchi.
Now they created that into a new park back in 1999
but they haven't done much to it,
So there's no reservation period.
Basically nobody really goes there.
And what I did is I went up through Chinakuchi River
but then I hooked up into Tomoghani.
So I went through a bunch of Tomoghani lakes
and then I hooked up to the Sturgeon River
and I went down the Sturgeon River back to Chinakuchi
And it's six, maybe eight days,
But it's one of the best canoe trips I can ever imagine,
because you've got a little bit about everything.
You've got amazing scenery like the quartzite mountains,
You've got a river that actually is doable.
It's not a dangerous river,
It's a very doable river, but it's a lot of fun.
And then you've got the big, huge white pine
and Tomoghani. you get a palace through
And it's fantastic.
And just make sure you go with a good person.
Social dynamics is more important on a trip.
You guys know that more than I do.
On the trip you just described with somebody
you didn't get along with very well
and you wouldn't really be looking at the quartzite mountains
all that much would you.
Because here's the thing: when you're in the wilderness,
you are who you are.
There's no faking your character,
There's no facade.
And if you don't like your boss, for example,
the best thing to do is take them on a canoe trip
in May, when the bugs are up,
Because they can't fake themselves.
And I love that. I love that about wilderness.
I am who I am out there,
You know. but you back really bad.
You have to sort of immerse yourself with it
and become you know, in one sense
living out there.
So the people you're with,
even if you go canoe-tripping with someone
and you never meet them
for 40 years,
you finally meet them. you're still friends.
Yeah, No, you're right about that
That's for sure,
Is that route that you were talking about,
one of those old routes
that you've opened back up.
It's an old canoe route
called the Nostagwan route.
there's another one that I did
this year up by Biscoe Tacing,
up by Mississaugee River.
It's sort of central north-central Ontario,
north of Lake Huron
And a couple places up there,
but one was Grey Owl.
He traveled that area a lot
when he was Archie Blaney,
when he was a ranger,
And he talks a lot about the Mississaugee River,
which is a beautiful river to do.
And I went to other places
and I went to talk to a lot of natives up there
And they said, well, there was an old canoe route
that was south of Biscoe Tacing,
where he lived,
And it links up
to what's called the Spanish River.
And so I did a 12-day solo
canoe loop through there
and retraced it and found the old cabin
that was kind of neat
that I was told that he stayed at
and, sure enough, the little scribblings inside.
Archie Blaney.
Now, we had huge problems here this summer.
I'm not sure if you guys have, but we had no water.
There was no water at all
And the weirdest thing is
because of that I had to change my route
all the time.
Places I thought I could go, I couldn't,
which was kind of neat
because I found other places that I would never have found.
And I found this old lodge
that was built in 1939
for the prince that was supposed to arrive
And the locals had built it.
Oh yeah, I read, you did an article about that, didn't you?
Yeah, yeah,
The neat thing about it is that
there's a story about it, whether it's true or not,
but I guess the locals say that
he got off the train and the black flies were so bad
he went back on the train
And they were so mad that he did that.
they burned the lodge around.
There's nothing left of it except an old chimney
and I actually found that chimney. so that was kind of neat.
I read that article- you reminded me of it
and it was a cool article.
and then it gets to the day, new mom,
where this royal
gets off the train
and is besieged by black flies,
And I thought
there is, if somebody doesn't know Canada,
there's like a perfect
Canada story right there.
Oh, yeah, yeah,
Because you got there. and oh yeah,
and I've experienced the first year we went up,
we went up
in June
and we learned that
going in August was a lot smarter,
because most of the black flies
and giant biting flies
and the mosquito airplanes
were pretty much
all gone in August.
Yeah, it's true,
If I was going to take any time off,
August, September,
it's the best time to go.
I go out in June a lot, which is just insane,
but I go out in June because I usually have
lots of time in June but also nobody
in the right mind would be able to do it.
I have you.
I mean, these things can
carry a person away. They're amazing.
You
think of what the black fly does
to you. If you try to
symbolize what Northern Wilderness is
in the springtime black fly,
you don't feel it by you. It slices your skin,
so it doesn't really hurt you
at first, And then it pulls your skin
apart with stylists and then it slices
you again and keeps slicing until it gets to the capillaries
And then it starts lapping the blood
up. and it needs to lap blood up for
at least three minutes to get enough blood
protein for it to have its eggs.
And then, when it's done, it pulls its head up,
but during that time it spits
salivating you so your blood doesn't clot,
Right. So if you actually hit the black fly
while it's hitting you
or biting you, then you'll
push all the salivating you and that's what irritates
the wound And you think a million
of those are doing that to you at one time.
That's Northern Ontario.
You know way too much
about that, Kevin.
I'm going to be happy in my ignorance
and come up in August.
That's true.
So you do
a fair amount of talking to scout groups.
Yeah, I've always
have. I mean, I was a scout
and I also.
I have a lot of background in outdoor education.
back in the 80s That's what I did
and
it's almost like payback time and
throughout the years I've always sort of volunteered to go
to scout groups and give a talk.
It's usually a humorous talk. It's usually like
sort of a burst of enthusiasm.
This is why you guys should go out and this is why
you did go out and
that sort of thing. Tell me a little bit more
about Grey Owl. I don't know that. a lot
of people know exactly who that was
and what the
story is there. Well, I think a lot of
scouts, scout leaders, would actually look
into this character and just find it very
intriguing for many
reasons. He was an Englishman that
really didn't like where he lived,
Didn't like his home, didn't like his family.
I'm not sure if he didn't like his family.
He just he was a dreamer
and he wanted to become a woodsman
and become a native in Canada.
So he moved over to Canada-
and this is back in the gosh 30s, 40s-
and
so what he did is he disguised himself up as a
native and the natives knew
that he wasn't a true
native, but they just ignored him. They said,
well, if he wants to be a native, he can be a native.
but then he became a writer and
then he became a conservationist and he was
on conservationists that saved the beaver
from extinction. actually,
He used to have a job trapping
and then one day he decided not to
trap and then he wrote books about it and then
he did films on
his pet beavers that
lived inside his cabin
down in a. you know,
he was an Alberta in a cabin
and he became a legend. but the thing is,
the day after he died,
then the newspaper reports came out
and said: oh, by the way, he wasn't a native,
he was Archie Blaine.
and you would think at that time
because of that, people would say, okay,
well, now the Wizard of Oz is now showing
itself that sort of thing. how dare he do that?
and he shunned, but he was
still celebrated and he's still celebrated to this day.
people are flying
with the idea that he disguised himself. Well, now I know
who to thank. every time I have to pull a canoe
over a beaver dam at,
I'll be thinking about him.
I got to tell you a good story.
I paddled in the United States once-
oh, no more than once, but I do remember
going to Maine
in the Outer Randax and
it's a busy place
and I was lining up to go paddling
but I went to this woman ahead of me and I said:
so what's so special about this river?
everybody seems to be lining up to do this
route. and she said: well,
this is really good because it's got those things
they have in Canada. what do they call?
they make mounds of sticks.
I went beavers. Yeah, yeah,
I went beavers dams on this river.
I went- you're kidding me-
and I packed up my stuff and went back to a gondola.
You mentioned bears.
I think that there are some people
below the parallel
who think Canada is just crawling with them
and it's a clear and present
danger. what can you tell us about
bears up in Ontario and
environments. Well, we have the black bear here,
we don't have the grizzly. it's not
really an issue if you look at it
statistically. since 1936
there's only been seven deaths
from a predatious black bear
in Ontario. actually,
I think even Canada. actually
there's so much more of a chance of you getting hit on the highway
by a car
than a black bear attacking you.
the only problem is
I'm very bare phobic, so I'm not going to be
going and telling you that actually
it's safe. you're okay, don't worry about it,
because I'm still just so bare
phobic as well.
but I like the idea that bears scare people out there.
it keeps a little bit more willingness out there.
just like the black flies,
it keeps people on their toes.
if you see a bear, it's a nice experience.
it's a nice wildlife sighting
and
using the bear as soon as it sees you
will be gone in a second.
if you spent your life not going into the
willingness because you're afraid of bears
and then you got hit on the highway,
it's not worth it.
I'd rather actually spend my life in the willingness,
maybe one day if it ever happens
and I get killed by a bear in the woods.
well, it's better than getting killed on the highway
and it's so much easier for the survivors
because there's not much to deal with
once you're gone.
that's true,
I mean, it's quite funny too.
my wife always tells me to never tell these stories.
but predacious bears,
how they kill you is they take your head off
because they think you're a moose cat,
and so the studies show that
even the people that got killed by these bears
didn't feel too much
okay. so I'm sure we've made
everybody very comfortable
about going into the woods up there.
when I was in a gunk one at one point
I was talking to one of the rangers there.
some of those guys go for several years
between bear sightings and they're in the park every day.
yeah,
it's funny. I see bears a lot.
a kree elder once told me that
the bear was my spirit and I said: can I change that?
is there any way I could do that?
but I was wondering why
the bears always came into my camp and he said:
well, the bears know you're afraid of them
and that's why they're harassing you more.
and he taught me a lot.
but then the bear story I had this summer
in tomography. it's a classic family adventure.
last morning we woke up and we're on an island
and thankfully
I woke up early and I see this bear
swimming to the island. and what that meant to me
was this bear had got food on that island
before, so it's coming to this island
for food from our stuff.
and I'm waking everybody up and it's okay.
we have a bear encounter here,
so everybody get prepared.
and my buddy was there
and he goes. well, my kids haven't seen a bear yet.
so could you wait before you scare it off?
could you wait for a while?
I went, you're kidding me, right?
I go, I want to scare this bear.
he goes. well, wait until it gets halfway.
and I said, look, once it's halfway,
that's it. I'm going to start shooting the bear bangers
and stuff. okay, okay, that's an agreement.
so we get all the kids and they're watching the bear swim
towards us and everybody's excited.
and then so the bears got halfway
and I said, okay, I'm doing the call,
so I get the bear bangers
shoot it over nothing, the bear just keeps swimming
towards us. and I went: oh, this is not good.
and then I shoot the flare
and the bear just looks at me.
well, then I ended up getting my paddle
and started bashing the paddle against the rock
and that worked. the noise of that scared the bear off.
but I broke the paddle
and the guy that was with
he made me that paddle
and he looks at me and goes: why did you do that?
and my daughter, right on cue, goes:
dad, it was my birthday
and that bear was coming to my party.
how dare you scare him away?
so obviously I was the only one
afraid of this bear,
so I thought it saved your life,
but
your book's a happy camper.
tell me a little bit about it.
that was a enjoyable book.
um, uh, years ago
I wrote a book called the ways the wild.
I think it was called- I'm not sure
we do it into a how to book-
and I ended up doing a little bit more sense
of humor to it. it could. it sold like 10,000
copies in the first month or something.
um, so we- which in Canada, by the way,
is huge like that, because the best seller
in Canada is 5,000 copies-
and, um, I was a little nervous
about it because it's it's how to.
so I'm telling people what to do, but
everybody says I'm a professional. but I'm not.
I, I call myself a person that just
loves camping, loves going out the
outdoors, and I learn from experiences.
so the book was based on my experiences.
so it was basically
this: is you know what not to do? because
I did it and then I
after that they want me to do a happy camper
too, and I kind of didn't want to do a happy
camper too. so I did another book called
willingness pleasures, and it was more about why
we go and why we
should keep going, and I really enjoyed
writing that book. um,
that sort of uh changed
into a thing I'm doing the less.
last year uh called the happy camper
online show and it's
it's, um, it's at kevincalincom
and it's basically just a bunch of videos- how
to videos- but it's all done with
humor and just uh, just yesterday we
launched the newest one was
all how to choose a good camp
and it's just silliness. we have a green
screen behind me and the weather's
changing every time I change my hat,
and but it's a lot of fun. now,
scouts actually. um, they just contacted
us and we- we just gave them the
okay to put all the, all the
videos they want on their what on their
own website. so, and they are really great.
um, I've put a couple of them
on the scout master blog
and I've gotten really favorable
comments about them. but they are
they. they're hilarious. I really
do enjoy those. and you've
got uh four uh
water walker film awards to your credit.
yeah, water walker is a um a thing
they have in Canada. it's all across
the world actually, but it's um based
in Ottawa and it's uh, people from all over
put their canoe films in
for um awards and
I I want a few of them. there's so many
places in the bush. you know. there's so many stories
up there. how, how did we find the film?
a YouTube site called Callan Canoe,
Callan Canoe. you go to Callan Canoe. there's
like endless videos. uh, I
always take a camera with me when I go on trips
and I do a lot of solo trips and I just have
the camera in the canoe. yeah, the Bisco tasting
route I did this year is all online
on that site too.
if I'm headed up to Ontario and I want
to get like a taste of some of the canoe routes
and some of the things up there, is there a good
online resource for that? it's
uh, explore dash
mag MAG and it's
explore magazine that I write for, but I
have a blog on there and what I do a
lot on that blog is I write a lot of my
trip journal notes, so, um,
so scouts would actually get a lot of that
and, uh, even a one I. one
trip I did a couple years ago was up by
LA Lake where we reopened a canoe
trip that closed in the 1980s
and, uh, rainbow trout were stocked there
in 1942 and they self-sustained themselves.
oh, and we got into these lakes,
were catching 10 pound rainbows that had
never seen a fly. I,
I'm hosting a contest, um,
that it's called the classic Canadian
adventure. but if you win- and anybody
in North America can win-
you and your three buddies,
um, go
seven days with me and we go to Ottawa,
we go whitewater rafting,
whitewater kayaking, we go flying through
Canyon in the balkan park with the M&R
turboplane, um, so, yeah,
we go to bonus share park and all
these other things. so it's kind of a neat contest
and, um, so some scouts
might be interested in that. let me make
sure I understood exactly. where do we
find the contest? but if you just go to my blog,
there's, um, there's a right
up on it with a video. hey, I'd love
to do this again sometime, no problem,
and actually, uh, we, we can even
um, if I'm in a balkan park on
a canoe trip, I can actually do the same, this
same thing. oh, no, kidding.
yeah, it's called a begin. it's a satellite
system that a company let us let us borrow.
wow, I do a lot of
uh TV stuff like that or radio stuff
around. I'm actually uh live
in the park and they even
do it by way of video so you
can actually see me in the park. are you going out
at all in the winter? yeah, in January.
I'm doing a winter trip in the
end of January in a, in a gawk one
actually. oh, that would be really cool.
yeah, it'd be fun. so, Kevin,
thanks so much for joining us.
uh, had a had a great time talking
to you. hope we interested some people
into uh checking out canoeing up there
in Ontario. oh, no
problem, Clark, thanks a lot and I hope to see you out there
on the portage or portage, or portage
or whatever you want to call it. how about this,
how about this? next time I'm up there, I'm going to
find you and we'll head over to
um. Tim Hortons
cup of coffee, maple dip-
I owe you one. that sounds good.
thanks very much,
music.
thanks so much for listening
to the 280th
edition of the scout master podcast.
here's how to keep in touch.
go to scoutmastercgcom
and there you can read our blog and you can
subscribe to receive updates to the blog by email.
you can join the other mobile
scouters who have the scout master
cg app on their mobile devices
and you can get the app in the google play
or itunes app store.
you can experience all the wonders
that are scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama
of social media outlets.
join the 9500 folks who like scoutmaster blog
on facebook. tweet along with
the chorus of 1200 tweeters
on twitter and pin the poultry tune
pictures that we profit publicly with
1900 other prolific pinners
on pinterest. watch us at scoutmastercg
on youtube or join
the 400 odd folks who form the
exclusive and very quiet scoutmaster
cg circle on google plus.
now, if you can't face facebook, if twitter
makes you better, if you've no interest in pinterest,
if you don't put the? u in youtube,
if you're a minus when it comes to google plus,
don't worry about it. that's okay. bunkie, zoom
into the late 90s and send me an email.
you can get in touch with me.
clarkgreen at clark
at scoutmastercgcom.
that's c-l-a-r-k-e
and let me remind you, please,
that the scoutmaster blog and the
scoutmaster podcast are not official publications
of anybody except for myself.
nope, they're not official publications
of any scouting organization like
the Boy Scouts of America, nor the
endorsed or sponsored by anybody.
no, it's just me talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to scouters
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
and speaking of fun,
here's our founder, Sir Robert Baden Powell.
Sir Robert,
good luck to you and good healthy
why? thank you, sir.
until next time, everyone.